so who exactly is Rihanna's hot new man
zendaya shuts down the spider-man
homecoming premiere Plus Niall Horan
wants Katy Perry to stop being mean and
is Adele never touring again no why are
you doing this to me Adele this is the
daily Denny I'm dating direct oh and we
begin today with some sad news
Adele may be done touring for good I
know I can't believe of uttering those
words out loud myself but that's what
seems to be the case et has confirmed
Adele included a handwritten note to
fans in a program at her London concert
last night in it the note said touring
is a peculiar thing it doesn't suit me
particularly well I only ever did this
tour for you she went on to say I wanted
my final shows to be in London because I
don't know if I'll ever tour again and
so I want my last time to be at home
Adele has been on tour for 15 months in
support of 25 with her final four shows
at Wembley Stadium now I saw here in LA
and it was unreal which is why this is
so devastating to hear it's just some
kind of sick joke you know she has said
in the past that she has stage fright
and is a homebody plus she's got her son
Angelo but damn Adele Beyonce was up
here performing at the Grammys sitting
courtside at basketball games pregnant
with twins so take your break but then
come back to us we need to hear those
pipes live girl all right now someone
who is showing no signs of slowing down
Rihanna girl knows how to get it and
she's getting it with a hot new man
right now if you don't know what I'm
talking about then you missed the
Rihanna has a man party on Twitter this
week Rihanna was snapped getting hot and
heavy in a pool with a mystery man now
we actually can't show you the pics but
trust
they made me bless but what we do have
for you is the two together in Ibiza
check out this dude smile yeah I'd be
smiling that big too if I was dating
Rihanna so just who is our new man well
his name is Hassan Jamil a businessman
whose family is worth 1.5 billion
dollars because their company has the
sole rights to South Toyota's and Saudi
Arabia Hassan was also previously linked
to Naomi
Campbell and get this sources tell us
Rihanna has been keeping this romance
under wraps since the new year quick
someone check on Drake oh that's right
we already did RiRi Zechs took rosslyn
go down whoo day to the NBA Awards just
a couple days ago a source tells ET that
they are just friends and have been for
a couple years now they are not dating
well then he better stay off Twitter
because everyone is really worried about
him right now
all right what do you guys think of
rereads man yay name or drink let us
know in the comment section below but
moving on to the epic Hollywood premiere
of spider-man homecoming Peter Parker
himself Tom Holland brought his entire
family along including his little
brother Patty how proud are you of your
big brother uh very proud yeah I try to
be like him good all surprised I try I
do I do a lot of auditions but never get
them maybe one day you can play
spider-man 2 in a reincarnation yeah
maybe a young smarter man
maybe we do a flashback you can be baby
Peter Parker I'll be the brother my
mom's brother yeah okay got to say it
was Ben daya who stole the show her hot
pink gown by Ralph and Russo was in fact
a showstopper and she even got a little
assist from her co-star Michael Keaton
Mayer loved this movie that comes out
next weekend you guys are in for a treat
plus I still have my interviews with the
cast which I have for you next week
cannot wait to show you all right but
moving on to former One Direction
heartthrob Niall Horan he thinks Katy
Perry is a big ol meanie this all
started after Katy revealed nyle asked
for her phone number to flirt with her
during which she said I could babysit
you and I could be your mom while Niall
fired back with this tongue-in-cheek
response while on Australian pop news
program the project kitty hey stop being
mean to me she just finding any excuse
now to just pass her knows me and go
around spreading rumors about me
I mean I just I just want to be her
friend ah see Katy
he just wants to be your friend why got
to be so cold to the kid
well to be fair it's probably because we
Katie met Niall as a judge on UK's the
x-factor he was 16 years old going on 12
look at that little cutie pie you just
want to pinch his cheeks and set him to
bed
still horn makes an excellent point
about the 32 year old Perry saying I
mean she is talking like she's 55 years
older than me she is not that much older
than me
true but they say you're only as old as
you feel and miss Perry has been going
through a lot lately so all I'm saying
is she's seen a lot people give her some
space
are you guys that's it for today thank
you so much for watching hit subscribe
on e t--'s youtube channel for more
daily denne we got one more tomorrow and
it's new music Friday and of course head
over each online.com for all the
headlines in the entertainment world and
until next time I'm out